stimulating fiber investment is a very
important aspect of FTTH and a half with
me Stefan Stanislavski who knows all
about that Stefan how much does it cost
well if we're going to fibre the whole
of the eu27 so that's 210 million homes
500 million population that would be 270
billion euros to do everything from
scratch some has already been spent a
course by the operators about 11 billion
and we sharing of ducks and reuse of
infrastructure it could come down maybe
towards 220 something like that it's a
little bit uncertain but it's a couple
of hundred billion euros and how do you
go about raising something like that
well that's a good question then there
are there are two answers it depends
whether you want to build quickly or
slowly so if you wanted to build quickly
there is a way called public-private
partnership that could be used in
countryside areas particularly where the
government will spend some money not as
a grant but year by year so it's like
pretend revenue and the company that
builds a network can borrow against that
and of course against the revenues from
customers and there's a well-established
formula project finance technique used
in many industries to build dams bridges
and so on that could be deployed what we
learned is there's no shortage of money
to invest in fiber in fact there are
funds desperate to invest in it but it's
a question the structure and the way
it's done the slow way is to ask the
telco to reinvest the money that they
are already paid for modernization so in
your phone bill and broadband bill every
month because the way the regulatory
cost model works there's an assumption
about the asset life so for an overhead
wire in Britain where we are today it's
18 years so the cost and the charge to
you is worked on the basis that whale
will be replaced every 18 years now that
obviously isn't happening because when
you average it out 18 years for overhead
and longer for fixed three or four
percent a year so every year we should
see three or four percent of home
connected to fiber and that is what the
customer is paying for and what's
surprising perhaps when you're new to
this is that that's not happening the
customer is not getting what they're
paying for that money is going somewhere
else mystery as to what it is but so the
slow way is to ask the telco really to
spend and do what they're paid to do
already by the customer that would get
us fiber everywhere in 25 years the
current rate progress sadly were on
track for the fiber switch over in 92
years which is a long time so what's
your feeling is it going to be a mixture
of both I think that's what will happen
it will be that make sure both the most
important political change would be a
commitment to a fiber switch over it's
entirely feasible and possible and that
25 year program would only use about
half of the existing annual capex budget
the telcos so it wouldn't disturb
dividends or any other feature of that
kind so I think that the frame of debate
has to change in what's the business
case and the benefit to why are we not
doing something that long term is
actually cheaper for the customer and
probably a bit more profitable for the
shareholder long-term and is eminently
affordable that's the real question it's
essentially a political question when
there's a commitment all the various
mechanisms and details they'll all fall
into place behind that leadership but we
need the leadership great okay well
thanks for talking to us you're welcome
thank you
you